[موسيقى]
لدينا ما يقرب من 3000 نوع من
النباتات والحيوانات تعيش داخل
غابات الكوكب الأخضر المطيرة في أي
وقت من الأوقات
تمثل مجموعة من الأصناف الاستوائية من
النباتات
ثم بالطبع الحيوانات التي تتراوح من
الببغاوات
إلى الأسماك إلى الزواحف والبرمائيات
وحتى الثدييات  مثل الخفافيش
والغرف العلوية
وآكل النمل
[الموسيقى]
يعد برنامج التخييم في الغابة المطيرة
الفرصة الوحيدة
في دبي لقضاء الليل في بيئة
استوائية
يصل ضيوفنا أولاً في الساعة السابعة صباحًا
وسيظهر أحد أعضاء فريقنا
أنت إلى خيمتك ،
لذلك سيكون لكل مستوى من غاباتنا
المطيرة خيمة واحدة حتى تتمتع
بخصوصياتك ومساحتك أيضًا
من هناك سيجتمع الجميع مرة أخرى
عند المدخل في الساعة
7:30 من أجل مطاردة زبال الغابات المطيرة حتى يتمكنوا
من القيام ببعض الشيء  لعبة
ما وتحصل على الروح التنافسية عندما
تتعرف على المنشأة
بعد انتهاء عملية البحث عن الزبال ،
سننتقل جميعًا إلى الخارج
لحضور حفلة شواء في الغابة المطيرة ، وبعد ذلك بمجرد
الانتهاء من تناول الطعام في المطعم.  الشواء
سنعود إلى الكوكب الأخضر هذه
المرة بمصابيح حمراء على
رؤوسنا ونختبر الكوكب الأخضر في
جولة ليلية لمشاهدة جميع الحيوانات
التي تستيقظ فقط في الليل إنها
تجربة مختلفة تمامًا بعد حلول الظلام
[موسيقى]
نحن  سنخرج لتناول بعض
قهوة ستاربكس وسمورز على نار المخيم
قبل أن تتمكن من العودة إلى الداخل لمشاهدة
أفلامنا التي تدور حول الحيوانات والتي تُعرض على
الشاشات العملاقة ،
وستكون الأنوار في منتصف الليل تقريبًا وبعد
ذلك سنستيقظ
لطيفًا في وقت مبكر  في الصباح في الساعة 6 صباحًا
للذهاب مع أحد علماء الأحياء لدينا وراء
الكواليس ، يساعد الفريق في
إعداد وجبات الصباح ثم المضي قدمًا
وسيتوجه الجميع لإطعام
الطيور والكسلان والقرود الإفطار
قبل الخروج إلى المنطقة
الخضراء الجميلة  مقهى الكوكب
لتناول بوفيه إفطار لأنفسكم
[موسيقى]
التخييم في تجربة الغابات المطيرة
خاصة إطلاقه هنا
هذا العام بعد خروجنا من الإغلاق كان
فرصة رائعة لسكان
دبي
لتجربة  ه إقامة
خارج الملعب تمامًا
بشيء مختلف
تمامًا ولديها فرصة للتخييم
في بيئة استوائية
[موسيقى]